hey david joe biden keeps talking about
compromising with republicans and
working across the aisle
is biden nuts for thinking this
republican party will compromise with
him
well this this requires some speculation
about what biden actually thinks and
believes
what i mean by that is i don't know that
joe biden really thinks this republican
party is going to work with him and in
fact
i doubt he thinks that i believe joe
biden is talking about
reaching across the aisle and getting
republicans to compromise
because he's trying to be a unifying
figure who at least appears willing to
reach out to republican
voters it makes him look presidential it
appeals to more than just the democratic
party
and it in a way puts pressure on
republicans
many are friends with biden remember
biden has a lot of republican friends
to try to rise above partisanship but
my belief is biden knows especially
because they've been clear
republicans will be obstructionist
buffoons
for the next at least two years likely
for
they will try to get in the way of any
accomplishment that the democratic party
tries to do and so i don't believe
joe biden's rhetoric about
bipartisanship
and compromise will go anywhere i think
with this republican party the only
the only way to get them to work with
biden would be to make such
significant concessions that these
legislative victories would end up being
pyrrhic victories in other words
victories in which you you you do you
are
so much damage is inflicted upon you
that you start to wonder is it really
even a victory
in the net so um i think you know if i
believed biden
naively believed mitch mcconnell is
going to help him get
the tax reform done that he wants and
the public option of course no
that would be insanely naive of joe
biden but i don't think he believes that
i
believe it's mostly posturing i believe
joe biden knows because republicans have
made it clear
they will obstruct absolutely everything
that they can
and i'm not particularly optimistic that
republicans are going to participate in
anything
over the next four years so what can joe
biden get done
without republicans what can joe biden
get done
uh with executive orders it remains to
be seen and
we'll be here for the ride we've got a
great bonus show for you today
make sure you're signed up for a
membership at joinpakman.com we have a
new coupon code
better21 the meaning should be obvious
we want to have a better
2021 than 2020 better 21. you can sign
up
now and be listening or watching today's
bonus show
within 60 seconds i promise you join
pacman.com coupon code better21